el reparto de vacunas para frenar al cob
y 19 se ha convertido en toda una
carrera contrarreloj en la que los
estados ricos están ganando mientras las
primeras imágenes de personas
vacunándose ya están dando la vuelta al
mundo hay una gran mayoría de países que
no esperan vacunar al grueso de su
población hasta 2022 algo que la o&m s
ya ha denunciado en varias ocasiones
wyss implica not a que no podemos
aceptar un mundo en el que los pobres y
marginados sean pisoteados por los ricos
y poderosos en la estampida por las
vacunas en por full end stamper for
vaccines
esto es una crisis global y las
soluciones deben ser compartidas como
bienes públicos globales no como
mercancías privadas que aumentan las
desigualdades
a private commodities that wider
inequalities el secretario general de la
onu antonio guterres acuñó el término
bakú nacionalismo que es anteponer el
interés particular de una nación por
encima del bien común un ejemplo de esto
podría ser canadá que ha comprado dosis
por cinco veces su población que apenas
supera los 37 millones de habitantes es
cierto que se han creado programas de
reparto equitativo como kóvacs pero éste
sólo garantiza vacunas al 20% de la
población
y creo que está claro que no podemos
confiar ni debemos confiar en las
acciones voluntarias o caritativas de
las empresas farmacéuticas
la historia nos dice que no tienen un
gran historial de anteponer el interés
público a sus fines de lucro
organizaciones como oxfam creen que los
gobiernos deberían garantizar el libre
acceso a las vacunas y no comerciar con
el exceso de dosis compradas ya que
apelan al interés común de terminar con
una pandemia que ha matado ya a más de
un millón y medio de personas en el
mundo